Vaginal births are OUT and surgical births
are IN!
So......yay science?
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Yall have heard of c-sections, right?
It's like...a surgical birth.
The surgeon makes an incision in mom's abdomen
and uterus to pull the baby out.
The Cesarean Section originally emerged as
an alternative to vaginal birth in the case
of an emergency.
For instance: if the umbilical cord prolapses
or --more commonly--if the labor fails to
progress.
In recent years, however, c-sections have
become WILDLY popular.
In 1970 only 1 in 20 newborn babies was delivered
via c-section and now it's....1 IN 3.
Some Obgyn's predict that it will be MORE
popular than vaginal birth in our lifetime.
Is this trend a problem?
Weeeeellll.....there are definitely some things
to consider.
For one, it's an actual surgery.
So like most surgeries, when it's not a medical
necessity, it increases the risk of complication.
C-section also carries triple the death rate
that vaginal birth does, and for the mom,
recovery is much longer and more difficult
- 20% of patients experience abdominal pain
for months.
For babies, those that aren't delivered vaginally
don't get the same exposure to their mom's
microbiome.
C-section babies have markedly fewer "good
gut bacteria", and they're at a higher risk
for allergies, asthma, and poor health later
in life.
It is also the case that more than a third
of c-sections in the US are performed too
early.
Of course, premature birth is a health risk.
So, why have c-sections become so popular
then?
One big factor is efficiency.
Doctors may find it more efficient to make
an incision and pull the baby out than to
have to guide the baby through the vaginal
canal.
Birth is also easier scheduling-wise if you
can just set a date and put it on the calendar.
This may help doctors run a tighter schedule
and patients to feel more in control.
It's also worth noting that one study found
unplanned c-sections spike right around the
end of the work day, between 3 and 4PM.
I actually know a woman who was pressured
by her doctor and he told her straight up
he had dinner plans.
Still, probably the largest force driving
an increase in c-sections is that, awhile
back, a handful of studies found that giving
vaginal birth to another baby after a c-section
may increase the chance that your uterus will
rupture.
However, more recent studies questioned the
findings, and found that this is the case
for...less than 1% of women.
In response to the trend, the American College
for OB/GYNS and the Society for Maternal-Fetal
Medicine are calling for fewer c-sections
with guidelines recommending that doctors
and patients allow the proper time it takes
for nature to take its course.
They say that the rates are too high and the
risks are too great -- and they advise that
doctors need to refocus on using the procedure
as a last resort.
What do you folks think about c-sections and
the current trend?
Let me know down below and we'll see you next
time!